có gì của gì của nó như thế hấp?
Anh chỉ là 1 có 1 đêm 1 người tình xác ngày thì bế lúc.
Đời nào mà cũng, nghe qua đúng gắng của vẻ mặt cú phục nóng.
Lú dân cao các thật chục cường khiến 2 OD bảo sạch trường xuân và phương thịnh vình thấp mời cú bị vớn
nước cô át chàn vào những chim hàng chăm hết ta lúc và vườn cây
gây trị thạch hàng tỡ đồng.
Cám cộng mất kia, chào tồng mất lắm, cáng thầy lưu vậy.
Nói sau khi sau trọng của mình và giả mất cán tầy lưu vậy.
Vĩnh gióam chào nhảm.
Mình mẹ tỏ lính đi đâu có có có chưa chơi chú chơi.
Hình đấy đúng, chơi chơi chơi chơi chơi chơi chơi chơi chơi chơi chơi chơi chơi.
Ở đó là phải nó có những này bầm giả để lúc hơi đó là cái trần.
Vụ hình thử dụng.
Nó có đó là cái gì chúng ta cho nó chơi chơi chơi chơi chơi chơi chơi chơi chơi chơi chơi chơi chơi chơi.
giữ sống và mặt có đông và mặt có tây tình tây nình, nước dân cao nhìn ngày qua
của khiến sảo chăm hích ta lua kia and trái và giá mầu của người dân vùng đồng
tháp mời bị thiết hại.
Hơn hai chăm cân nhàng gặp nước.